it gets deeper and deeper every day we
start with breaking news another glaring
example of political bias at your
Department of Justice our very own James
Rosen he joins us tonight with an
exclusive report James gets bigger every
minute Sean good evening when Fox News
first queried the Justice Department
about associate Deputy Attorney General
Bruce or a top official just four doors
down from deputy AG rod Rosen Stein we
were told that or had been stripped of
his title in his office a few hours
before our inquiry later DOJ told us
that or had lost that job because he is
also and remains director of do J's
organized crime Drug Enforcement Task
Force and that his wearing of two hats
was quote unusual finally this afternoon
DOJ officials acknowledged the real
reason for or stunning demotion
yesterday namely that he withheld from
superiors his meetings last year with
two controversial figures investigators
for the House Intelligence Committee
have uncovered that or met with
Christopher Steele the former British
spy who authored the infamous anti-trump
dossier with input from Russian sources
and he also met with Glenn Simpson the
founder of fusion GPS the opposition
research firm that paid Steele with
funding from the Clinton campaign and
the Democratic National Committee the
dossier was given to the FBI in July
2016 around the same time that Donald
Trump accepted the GOP nomination former
FBI director James Comey has described
the dossier as a collection of salacious
and unverified material about mr. Trump
and his associates I'm not sure when the
FBI first took possession of it but the
media had it before you had it and we
had it at the time of your departure
from the FBI was the FBI able to confirm
any criminal allegations contained in
the steel document mr. chairman don't
think that's a question I can answer in
an open setting because it goes into the
details of the investigation Republican
investigators from the House
Intelligence Committee issued a fresh
subpoena on DOJ today for information on
Bruce or they are looking to determine
whether the Democratic funded dossier
was used to obtain FISA surveillance on
a trump campaign adviser named Carter
page Shawn big question James Rosen
thank you tonight from Washington
this whole thing I tell you is a house
of cards it's beginning to crash down I
promise you there's a lot more
information that has still not come out
as of yet tick-tock to all our friends
out there on Twitter because we're only
scratching the surface here for example
Sarah Carter reporting tonight House
Intelligence Committee Chairman Devin
Nunez will issue a subpoena to Bruce or
for more information about his meetings
regarding this anti-trump dossier and
also tonight House lawmakers grilling
the FBI director Christopher ray on
Capitol Hill about new information
regarding the Trump hating FBI agent
Peter struck after struck was fired from
Robert Mulder's investigation why from
bashing Trump in text messages to his
FBI official girlfriend also part of the
team now before we show you the video
remember struck signed the document that
started the entire Russian investigation
and struck steam was assigned to handle
the dossier when it was first given to
the FBI and struck oversaw the interview
of former National Security Advisor
Lieutenant General Michael Flynn any
played a key role in the Clinton email
investigation this guy never slept
including by the way attending Hillary's
FBI interview that was not under oath
he was also there at the interviews of
Clinton's top aides Huma Abedin Cheryl
Mills who we know lied and struck is
responsible for changing in the key
language in James commis statement that
exonerated Hillary Clinton before the
investigation from grossly negligent
which is the legal standard to extremely
careless now that you have all this
information take a look at this showdown
it's epic from today but we've learned
about FBI agents trock is that this is
the one FBI agent that is literally at
the EPI epicenter of every virtually
every major decision the FBI has been
involved in action and inaction about
candidate Trump about President Trump
and about candidate Clinton and if that
one agent at the center or source is
decidedly anti Trump and decidedly
pro-clinton that raises real questions
I'm sure you're aware of the recent
media reports indicating that Peters
struck who is a special agent at the
b i changed the words grossly negligent
- extremely careless in former director
Comey's statement closing the clinton
investigation gross negligence is the
language in the statute I believe but I
believe also that almost anybody who
grabbed a thesaurus would say the gross
negligence and extremely careless are
pretty darn close to each other you're
right they are synonyms extremely
careless is a synonym for grossly
negligent which begs the question why
change it how did this guy get on you're
supposedly unbiased team in the first
place if you watch today you saw
something that we have been telling you
now for a long time that other networks
that say they're fair and balanced and
objective and they consider themselves
to be real journalists never talk about
pretty amazing now Peter struck that's
the Trump aiding Clinton loving FBI
agent he's tied to everything including
the fake news dossier watch very closely
an amazing moment Congressman Jim Jordan
connecting all of the dots you know kind
of like we've been doing on this show
why because it's the truth something
missing in today's world of so-called
journalism which I said was dead back in
o8 take a look Peter struck the guy who
ran the Clinton investigation
interviewed Mills Abidine interviewed
Secretary Clinton changed gross
negligence a crime - the term extreme
carelessness who ran the Russian
investigation who interviewed Mike Flynn
gets put on Muller's team and then he
gets kicked off for a text message
that's anti-trump if you kicked
everybody off Muller's team who was anti
Trump I don't think there'd be any value
left so here there's got to be something
more here my hunch is it has something
to do with the dossier director did
Peter struck helped produce and present
the application to the FISA Court to
secure a warrant to spy on Americans
associated with the Trump campaign
congressman I'm not prepared to discuss
anything about a FISA process and this
nothing did Peter struck was he involved
in taking that to the court I'm not
going to discuss in this setting
anything
to do with the FISA Court applications
it's been reported that this dossier was
all dressed up by the FBI taken to the
FISA Court and presented as a legitimate
intelligence document that it became the
basis for granting a warrant to spy on
Americans and I'm wondering you know I'm
wonder if that actually took place it
sure looks like it did now what
congressman Jordan is talking about and
what we have now been getting up for
months is this is critical to the entire
so-called Russian investigation you got
everybody in the liberal mainstream
destroyed Trump media trying to make
this all about non-existent Trump Russia
collusion it's been a year no evidence
but they've all been missing the point
and frankly deliberately misleading and
lying to you the American people they're
lazy and they're overpaid it's pathetic
the big story in all of this is the
growing possibility yes it's emerging
that the FBI used the Clinton bought and
paid for Russian dossier to obtain a
FISA warrant to spy on American citizens
that were connected to candidate and
then president-elect Trump now that
would be weaponizing the very powerful
tools and using them against an
opposition party in an election year now
let's be clear here it's not a smoking
gun quite yet but it's coming but that's
all where the signs now are pointing to
will follow this every single step of
the way we're ahead of the curve please
stay with us and one more very important
point can anyone explain to me anybody
at all how Robert mullahs investigation
can be described as fair impartial not
biased let's imagine for just a second
it's you it's your family member or
somebody that you love and care about
your friends would you really want
Robert Muller and his team of partisan
political hacks investigating you would
you want a group of people that donated
over $50,000 to the Democrats and filled
with unethical officials and attorneys
coming after you
that hate one candidate love the other
candidate would you really trust them to
be fair do you think this is how the
judge
the system is supposed to work because I
don't think so
and also tonight yes no class Barack
Obama back again what is he doing
launching a new far-left attack against
presidents from warning that America
could turn into Nazi Germany now he's
speaking at the Economic Club of Chicago
and Obama said the danger today is quote
growing complacent we have to tend to
this cordon of democracy or else things
could fall apart quickly that's what
happened in Germany in the 1930s which
despite the democracy of the Weimar
Republic and centuries of high-level
cultural and scientific achievements
Adolf Hitler rose to dominate 60 million
people died so you got to pay attention
and you got a vote all right very cute
very clever comparing the president in a
subtle way to Hitler and Nazis Obama by
the way how are your unrepentant
domestic terrorist buddies Bill Ayers
and Bernardine Dohrn doing oh and by the
way please send our best wishes to the
Church of Gd America and the Reverend
Jeremiah Wright now the former president
is obviously sick pathetic and twisted
in this obsession with President Trump
is kind of like everybody in the media
and every single chance Obama guess
whether it be here at home home overseas
doesn't matter he's trashing trying to
undermine the president maybe he can't
get over the fact that his record was
atrocious maybe he needs to take his own
advice and accept the results of the
election okay President Obama Hillary
lost time for you to to get over it by
the way I know this is probably
impossible but maybe try taking some
notes from george w bush because george
w bush never criticized you not one time
after he left office because he actually
respected the office more and thought it
was more important finally tonight over
a conspiracy TV MSNBC crazy liberal joe
and his cohorts over at that network
well they're at it again now stooping to
a new low attacking and trying to
discredit the president and a segment
only chicken little could be proud of
liberal Joe and his panel of never Trump
hating sycophants had a collective
meltdown during some deranged
reckless speculation about the
president's health watch this he is
clearly slurring his words I don't know
what the cause of it is the question of
his fitness of his of his stability is
in the air at the beginning of the
speech before the slurring started I
said Miko look at him this is not the
person that we knew even three years ago
he does not look in great physical shape
and hasn't for some time now it's
Republicans that are coming to us and
saying the President of the United
States is not mentally fit they're not
mentally fit to host a TV show there you
have it
armchair conspiracy psychology from
America's most unhinged liberal morning
show host and his band of merry Trump
haters it makes you wonder why liberal
Joe has so much rage and contempt for
this president show you kind of scaring
us I'll pay for therapy if you need it